[Music]
located in a waterfront park known as
Gardens by the bay is super tree Grove
this mechanical forest is a utopia for
nature in a very urban location super
tree Grove was commissioned by the
Singapore government with the intention
of raising the quality of life for its
residents by enhancing greenery and
flora in the city this man-made
mechanical forest consists of 18 super
trees the trees range between 80 to 160
feet high and are connected by a walkway
which allows visitors to cross between
them and view the city from the treetops
with their thick trunks and network of
thin neuron like branches
each tree acts as a vertical garden
over a hundred and sixty thousand
varieties of orchids ferns and other
climbing plants have been planted in the
trees the trees also generate solar
power eleven of the trees are fitted
with solar photovoltaic systems that
convert sunlight into energy this
provides lighting that allows the trees
to come alive at night making this an
all day all season horticultural heaven
[Music]
if you're having trouble finding mr. or
mrs. swipe right it might be time to
turn to mash makings ancient roots
literally because deep in a forest in
Germany stands a 600 year old oak tree
that has introduced hundreds of single
people
[Music]
it all began around 1890 when the forest
rangers daughter met a chocolate maker
from Leipzig the father did not approve
of the relationship they had to find a
way to exchange messages they used a
tree about 300 feet away from the forest
rangers office a branch had broken off
forming a hole and it was there they put
their letters once her father learned
how they were secretly communicating
he finally approved of their
relationship they married under the tree
On June 2nd 1891 after which the tree
became known as bridegroom's oak yet the
ALF gobble
i double-dare I just move down to this
like the pasta presses sat dr. dezube
advances do party ups idea the hides are
deceived your odds are team to the
office and people still send letters to
the tree to this day but can you truly
find a life partner for the price of
postage no one knows better than Karl
Heinz my table is Conrad Spartans sworn
in our team
but this is tonight scientific and a
party cups I should our team approach
the surface excretion Potok the father
toasted baguette scope collectible 2003
50 gr rtt portable table previous
victory also got the built us a million
dollars she start off in America the
whole 53:4 house the housing johan
andersson lately showed their preferred
trusted entity that we should be
standing in common
yeah it's about deceptive oh honey I
think you should form prefab Socata but
there was one letter that caught his eye
its best as he can attend my trip
Oakland in Babette aligned his that
effort at l have to be a good key file
cannot hides the touch Peter have was an
impacted Kavya is it nothing for 500
[Music]
by default by Rivini kite and the tough
over to hire that happen dr. Scott's
called situs Ernest City showed the
service manager shot is the ouster alum
is who that's had I intended I'm Joo Dee
that kid to get the out but it
essentially by the Justice I'd managed
defense this is the story of a plant
but not just any plant it is the story
of a plant that long long ago once ruled
the world a plant that today it's the
very last of its kind it's this plant
behind me encephalitis woody I II woody
I for short and I've been looking after
it for over 20 years it was named for
British botanist John medley wood who in
1895 discovered it growing on a hillside
on the coast of South Africa the strange
handsome plant caught his eye and he
carefully removed a small portion of it
and had it shipped all the way to London
to here Kew Gardens where it's been the
last 117 years but its history goes much
much further back you see in settle
artists woody I is what is known as a
sonic head and sonicate have been around
for 300 million years as a millennion
rolled on sonic heads flourished
providing shade for Triceratops a perch
for pterodactyls and a tasty snack for
brontosauruses at one point during the
Jurassic psyche heads made up 20% of all
the plants on earth and covered every
corner of the globe
but the good times couldn't last forever
the dinosaurs went extinct ice ages came
and went
new modern plants like conifers and
fruit trees started pushing cycads out
and
once proud population of e woody eyes
were reduced and reduced and reduced and
so there was possibly only one left one
single solitary II would I grown quietly
on a hillside which brings us right back
to John medley would at the time he had
no way of knowing just how rare his
discovery was but expedition after
expedition in search of more a woody I
have proved fruitless you see psyche
heads are delicious meaning you need
separate male and female plants to
create a new one and this one happens to
be a male a true lonely bachelor if a
female mate cannot be found it really
will be the last of its kind
to this day researchers are still
looking after all it's a big world and
might just be a chance in the meantime
we'll have me to keep him company
[Music]
little treats there a rearview mirror
staple protecting noses from offensive
odors all over the world but where do
they come from over 60 years ago a
scientist by the name of Julius Amon had
a chance encounter with a milkman that
changed the course of the air freshener
game forever it was in Watertown New
York a milkman was making the rounds
when he stopped to speak to Julius a
German Jewish chemist who fled the Nazis
and studied out buying tree aromas in
the forests of Canada said milkman began
venting to Julius about the stench that
spoiled milk left in his car and thus
the quest began to destroy bad car odors
Julius drew inspiration from the tree
aromas he studied by infusing their oils
onto paper in 1954 he filed a patent for
tree shaped paper infused with odor
destroying air perfume Julius then
started producing the air fresheners out
of an empty auto shop and sending
samples to local gas stations the little
trees were a big hit and Julius
successfully created the first
automotive air freshener though the look
remains the same the scents are forever
changing now the little tree company has
over 60 cents and has sold over a
billion little trees worldwide in the
Northwest region of Cambodia there's a
site like none other
where trees rise from rooftops and roots
make their way through walls this is top
Rome a 12th century Buddhist temple
that's become one with the jungle
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]